welcome back it's time for the fastest
first up greg has been teasing this all
show
it's tube and time people cnn is getting
called out for giving legal analyst
jeffrey toobin a second chance
the network welcoming him back after
tubin was fired by the new yorker for
exposing himself to co-workers during a
zoom meeting
here's his apology obviously
i wasn't thinking very well or very much
and
it was something that was inexplicable
to me i think one
point i wouldn't exactly say in my
defense because nothing is really in my
defense
i didn't think i was on the call i
didn't think
other people could see me it was wrong
it was stupid and i'm trying to be a
better person
hmm okay greg over to you
about the interview is that you could
see his hands so that's important
and i was told i was told by an insider
at cnn that they had the whole interview
on a seven second delay
in case he started frantically
masturbating uh which i thought was
important
um i actually think that the apology
was worse than the sin because uh when
you when you
if you leave your laptop on while you're
doing that that could be an
honest mistake but that was a deliberate
travesty
i would have loved to have been in the
meeting when they came up with this and
who to decide who to do it like
what did alice and camarado do to
deserve this i have no idea she
she was on red eye once you remember
that yeah but anyway my favorite part
about this is that he's painting this as
a character flaw
and like i'm going to solve this by
making amends by going to a food
i went to a food bank and i feel bad for
the food bank because
this is where all white rich guilty
liberals go
when they've done something wrong i'm
going to volunteer at a food tank
meanwhile all the people go away
please don't touch the food mr tubin
please don't touch the food
i'm just so glad he doesn't work here
because if i had to be on camera with
him
i would use every horrible foul
metaphor that i possibly could like ah
jeffrey good thing you came clean
it's too much he's so gross he's damaged
there were women on that call he knew
what he was doing
even james comey the emo giraffe said
get a little camera cover
on your laptop because they're spying on
you and if you can see them
they can see you and if if you're so old
that you don't know that only your
microphone is muted
you shouldn't be fumbling with the
gherkin
during a zoom call i think don't smear
gherkins
or just fully leave the call if you're
getting
that not clothes
[Laughter]
i could watch it i defer my rest of my
time to greg i could watch it every
single day for the rest of my life
to get a little bit more serious i'll be
the liberal stick in the mud here
uh stick in the mud that's disgusting
there we go
oh i didn't even get that but here we
are um
a lot of the twitter reaction has been
around
the fact that it is impossible that
someone not in his category as a white
man would get the opportunity to
rehabilitate themselves if it was a
woman if it was a person of color
that there you would never be seen on a
cable news screen again what do you
think i agree with it there's no way i
could do that and keep my job
not a chance do not disagree let's
it's definitely friday we have to move
on to
talking about geriatrics and emojis so
grandma and grandpa have been getting
tech savvy one in three older folks now
prefer sending texts emojis
and gifts not just i think over
traditional phone calls
and some of their favorite emojis
include the heart the happy face and the
beer emoji
this shocks me zero percent that those
are also their emojis of choice when
there are like incredible ones you could
be using
yeah but when my mom when my mom
discovered an emoji
it was like the heavens part of them
does she have a bad emoji
she does not yet but my daughters will
probably show her that this summer
but she does she every single text
doesn't matter if it's
a 20 line conversation the minimum of
six emojis
and we're talking you know rainbows
unicorns hearts
pink hearts little two hearts together
it fits she laughs
all the way is that gonna have to
breathe you have older people in your
life sending you
hearts well i just want to point out
that this is a segment on seniors in
technology and do you know who else was
a senior
jeffrey toobin
[Laughter]
yes i mean this that could have been his
senior moment you know
he didn't know the technology he didn't
know the technology he's like 70 right
no grandfather he he just had a young
kid
he should have a show sponsored by
seattle you know what he should have his
own emoji
you should have like an eggplant that
already exists
it's 100 friday uh what does your mom
send you in the emoji department she
overuses them
she's part of the problem no it's not
because i don't understand it
you don't speak your mom's emoji
language i try and then she facetimes me
and explains
like you know son i meant this when i
said this so you should have picked that
right mom
yeah no i think it's given them new life
um she's also discovered my mother the
the gifts yeah and those come freely um
but
my camera i use different pooh bear
gifts for everything like there's always
a great pooh bear
like trying if you feel fat you can't
get it no that's a fashion trend yeah at
uh coachella where guys can
wear the shirt hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else